so some of you may have heard a man
named Henry Cavill Cavill I don't know
has been cast as the new Superman in
Zack Snyder's film Superman I have
absolutely no idea who that is and
that's really the common thread with
casting Superman I mean Christopher
Reeve wasn't unknown when they cast him
Brandon ralph was an unknown when I cast
him they just seemed to be wanting to
only cast unknowns and I can understand
that it's a good idea but I don't always
know if it's the best today I mean think
about it Christian Bale not an unknown
he was Batman
Tobey Maguire not an unknown where he
was spider-man and they all turned out
really well
Zack Snyder is a good director I'm kind
of happy that he's directing the
Superman because I really like legend of
the Guardians last year I thought it was
really underrated I think you can bring
something interesting to it definitely a
completely different viewpoint than
what's been done before that's for sure
so oh I'm fairly positive about this I
don't really know much about this actor
there's no way he can ever top
Christopher Reeve I mean come on
you can't top that you just can't and I
kind of think of playing about it right
now this doesn't really make sense
basically just because we don't know
anything about him he could be an
excellent actor who knows I mean
complaining about it right now seems
like parents complaining about a child
that's not even born yet I mean it's
just not right I've always liked
Superman because I grew up liking the
original films with Christopher Reeve I
think he was fantastic as Superman
there's no way anyone would ever replace
him he's irreplaceable I mean come on
I say again no one can replace
Christopher Creek and you know honestly
Brandon Ralph's I didn't mind him I
thought he was alright I could have gone
with another friend Ross family just a
brief reminder don't forget about that
you reviewers movie awards or if some
people have called it the your reviewers
Movie Awards coming in February stay
tuned to the schmoes know channel and
Jeremy John's Tom childish for the film
fat desmos huge reviews Gavin dad and
myself are all going to be part of this
subscribe to them if you haven't already
up stay tuned for more information and
let me know in the comments below what
you think of this new Superman news
thanks for watching